que el lindo empezar un día tratando
temas tan importantes como son los del
cambio climático pero pero quiero
comentar que estamos hablando un
lenguaje que no refleja la realidad de
la amenaza cuando hablamos de cambio no
necesariamente estamos hablando de
amenaza cambiarse de zapatos cambiar de
trabajo cambiar de país cambiar de
universidad o de escuela son todos los
cambios positivos entonces porque el
cambio climático va a ser malo y quiero
resaltar este tema porque hay muchísima
gente que nos escucha todos los días que
dice pero porque se alarma si cambio es
bueno por lo tanto lo que propongo y que
ya a algunos de nosotros que trabajamos
en este campo lo estamos haciendo es que
cambiemos la terminología de cambio
climático
y sistemática la palabra 'crisis' si nos
diste algo más no cierto no nos da un
mensaje de amenaza que tenemos que tomar
en cuenta y por lo tanto reaccionar el
segundo tema que me parece súper
importante cuando hablamos de crisis
climática es que por alguna razón no
hemos hecho los suficientes esfuerzos
para que el común de la gente entienda
que queremos decir con crisis climática
la ciencia no debe pertenecer solamente
a los científicos el 99% de las personas
en este planeta no sabe interpretar los
mensajes de crisis climática hablamos un
lenguaje demasiado complejo demasiado
difícil inclusive términos como la
captura de carbono si no entiende qué
quiere decir eso cómo actúo como soy
parte de la solución
por lo tanto también ahí tenemos un
importante desafío todos que es
interpretar la ciencia para que el común
de los ciudadanos de todas las
profesiones y de todos los lugares
idiomas y nacionalidades pueda actuar en
función de lo que entiende cuál es el
problema
un tercer tema que creo que es súper
importante y como escuchamos en la
introducción de que todas las crisis
están interconectadas es que el cambio y
la crisis climática están íntimamente
relacionadas con la biodiversidad y la
destrucción de los ecosistemas
y la crisis clima está climática no
surge porque si sale de un abuso de un
uso inadecuado de la biodiversidad y de
los ecosistemas que destruimos todos los
días y que son los causantes de estos
cambios que generan la crisis una crisis
que se nos va de las manos si no
actuamos con mucha más intensidad ahora
porque quiero hablar con ustedes sobre
pérdida y desperdicio de alimentos y
cómo se relaciona este tema con crisis
climática y con la destrucción de los de
la biodiversidad y de los ecosistemas
porque el desperdicio de los alimentos
es una de las fuentes más importantes de
emisión de gases que destruyen nuestro
país nuestro planeta piensen ustedes que
si el desperdicio y la pérdida de
alimentos fuese una nación fuese un país
sería el tercer país emisor de gases
primero la china después los eeuu y
después la pérdida y desperdicio de
alimentos esa es una realidad y es una
realidad que tenemos que enfrentar
porque no la estamos considerando en
nuestro lenguaje diario en nuestras
conversaciones
de temas de todos los días y tenemos que
hacer
porque en la pérdida y desperdicio de
alimentos está destruyendo la naturaleza
está destruyendo la biodiversidad está
destruyendo los 12 años está elevando la
temperatura del agua de los océanos y
por lo tanto está destruyendo los
arrecifes de coral por ejemplo de los
cuales 50% de todos los mares del
planeta han desaparecido ya
y eso es un riesgo porque estamos
hablando de que los océanos son parte de
la fuente de alimentación y de la
seguridad alimentaria de todos los seres
humanos
este esta crisis climática
este cambio de temperatura también está
afectando algo que nos toca muy cerca a
los quiteños a los ecuatorianos
la disminución de tamaño de los
glaciares de nuestros antes esos
glaciares que nos dan agua todos los
días que nos proveen de vida porque no
hay agua y no hay vida no es cierto qué
haríamos sin ella y ahí está las
evidencias están allí entonces cambio
climático agua alimentos nuestro
comportamiento en relación a los
alimentos son parte del mismo problema y
están íntimamente conectados
pero nuevamente no solamente estamos
hablando de que se emiten gases algo
difícil de entender no cierto pero es un
tema en el que podemos actuar porque
todos somos parte del problema y todos
somos parte de la solución podemos hacer
cambios en nuestros hogares cuando vamos
a restaurantes cuando vamos a hoteles en
la planificación diaria en nuestros
hogares podemos medir mejor lo que
compramos lo que no medir lo que votamos
y actuar por supuesto
y por qué es importante vincular esto
con la agricultura porque una tercera
parte del agua que se utiliza en la
agricultura es desperdiciada y esa agua
es la que nos está dando la vida todos
los días en la agricultura el abuso y la
destrucción de los suelos por técnicas
inadecuadas y el abuso de agroquímicos
son parte del problema pero regreso al
tema de pérdida y desperdicio de
alimento
y su relación íntima entre eso y la
agricultura es justo que 800 millones de
personas se van a dormir sin comer esta
noche
no es justo si es que nos damos cuenta y
realmente digerimos esta información de
que la tercera parte de los alimentos
producidos en el planeta se van a la
basura podemos hablar de hambre
no será mejor de hablar de ética
pero lo interesante es que sobre este
tema hay muchísimas respuestas alrededor
de todo el mundo aquí en nuestro ecuador
en quito el banco de alimentos por
ejemplo que recoge todos los días y
semanas toneladas de comida de los
mercados de los supermercados de los
restaurantes que no han podido dar
ofrecer a sus clientes todos los
alimentos que han preparados estos están
ya siendo distribuidos a gente que no
tienen los medios para adquirir comida
todos los días en estocolmo donde donde
el bolsillo del consumidor está
amenazado cuando entra a un restaurante
a un buffet y un letrero le dice sírvase
lo que va a comer porque lo que deja en
el plato le vamos a cobrar
qué impacto tiene eso en inmediato en el
consumidor cuándo piensa qué locura dejo
en el plato una cantidad de comida que
me serví sin que sea necesario hacerlo
la cantidad de tiendas que están
vendiendo productos agrícolas que no son
perfectos y que no son aceptados por los
supermercados tiendas que ofrecen
zanahorias que no son de la medida
perfecta y tomates y naranjas y manzanas
pero que tienen el mismo sabor de
aquellas que están en buenas condiciones
entonces tenemos acá un desafío
maravilloso y es el tomar la decisión
que si somos parte del problema somos
también parte de la solución y la
solución es súper fácil empezar a actuar
en la familia con los vecinos en la
escuela y en el colegio en la oficina y
en el barrio todos comemos todos sabemos
que nos gusta comer y todos sabemos que
algo tenemos que hacer